this morning clark county school
district finds itself without a leader
superintendent dr jesus jar has been
fired that board meeting went late into
the night several hours a very heated
debate the school board of trustees
eventually voted to remove the
superintendent we've got hector mejia
joining us now to give us the latest
what had transpired during all those
hours yeah the school board has clearly
been divided for a while and last night
immediately after the school board voted
dr jesus jarrah out as superintendent
the focus then turned to board president
linda cavazos another major discussion
and it was whether to remove cavazos's
title as head of the board more
fireworks in the room harsh words
between trustees board member lola
brooks accused cavazos of micromanaging
and creating a toxic environment but
that motion was eventually tabled
postponed for some other day and
throughout the night we heard several
disruptions that got in the way of
public comments
security can we please have those exit
doors closed for safety
people at the at the exit doors please
move away all of this doesn't need to be
going on right now you are wasting far
too much time on this
and as a matter of fact if dr jar were
to go i would say the seven of you
should go also yes the motion to
terminate dr gyara's contract passed
four to three trustees cavazos cepeda
ford and guzman voted to fire him jarrah
read a statement saying his focus has
always been to improve the well-being
and academic success of students then he
left the room the school board now faces
the huge task of finding a replacement
ccsd did not announce a clear cut
timeline for what happens next back to
you guys